[Music]
david ortiz mlb on fox analyst
three-time world series champ and uh he
joins us on the program courtesy of a
t-mobile we'll get to that sponsorship
in a moment would you take your career
over tom brady's big poppy
why should i
well i know i'm just curious like you
know it's a red sox town
no man tom is uh i'm a big fan of tom
i'm a really good friend with him
of him and uh
he's uh he's something special man i
mean he's
he's someone that uh we all love even if
uh
um
going to tampa moving to tampa i mean
him and uh independently got the reason
but i know he's gonna be a big fan of
him and i love that guy that's my man
how do you think you'd do as a football
player
i'd be a badass man
but i'm guessing you didn't play
football growing up
no because in the dominican we don't we
don't really have football football how
we came to be uh
in a sport that uh
we we
we really haven't uh uh
every the dominican
uh guys that we can to be football
player they basically are either
born and raised in in america coming
from dominican family or
they come
accidentally born into the country
and and and the bellows baseball player
we don't we don't have
that sport in the dominican not yet
um what did you say from your world
series champion teams
man i mean
we we had the opportunity to have really
good
uh chemistry really good players
that developed and because winning a
world series man is so complicated like
it's this but like your uniform did you
keep uniform or bad or lineup or any
memorabilia from those uh world series
teams
oh yeah i have tons of memorabilia i
just i just don't know where they are
they are somewhere in the house do you
have anything in the hall of fame
i think i do
i think i do i think i have something
out there
i always was asked for things to uh
bring him over so i'm pretty sure i got
some some some more ability out there it
must be nice that you have so much stuff
that you can't remember where it is
poppy
it is unbelievable yeah i i mean
honestly
i bump into things sometime in my house
that i'll be like
you know it's crazy it's crazy um you
know when you watch the world series
what is it about moments that you see
guys like yourself
like they just become different when it
comes to playoffs in world series what
is it about the moment
well
you know
time have changed uh we i mean if if you
don't upgrade yourself to the time if
you if you if you don't adjust yourself
to the time you you will definitely be
left behind you know and and watching
this kid nowadays
the talent the performance you know like
the other day
uh during the show i realized that for
example a guy like altuve
who have played who haven't i mean he
had been in the playoff i mean
quite a bit but when you compare a guy
like a two best
the time that he had playing the playoff
to a guy like daddy jeter
you'll be like man
definitely play more
hap i mean he end up playing more
than
2 already matched his number and
probably went over his numbers you know
what i'm saying yeah it's something that
is very impressive you know i realized
that two had 20 home runs in a play
after a day
and i was like
20 home runs crazy you know what it
takes to hit 21 runs in the playhouse
you know what i'm saying so
uh uh
it's enjoyable
it's something that uh
it's it's it's enjoyable it's something
that uh
i i enjoy
watching it's something that uh
uh the fans are enjoying it and i'm
pretty sure
uh uh
we're gonna continue uh uh
you know just
i i'm i'm having so much fun uh watching
it
if you could pitch to one of the two
jeter or altuve
game on the line
you got a pitch to one of them
i had to preach to one of them yep
game's on the line
man you put him in the spot
to be honest with you because
jira was special
you know what i'm saying like like you
you jitter can come through with a hit
at any time but it can hurt you even
more because it can take you deep
guy got power you know
it's it's a small guy but he has
incredible power and
and and it's something that goes a long
way
you know i know that you were around
when schilling had his injury but
there's charlie morton on the mound with
a broken leg last night still pitching
and striking out altuve i mean that
that's a a 100 mile an hour liner coming
back to to break his leg and
still being able to pitch he wanted to
stay in i mean pretty incredible
that was impressive that was impressive
and that tells you how much
uh guys
want to be able to
uh provide for the booklet you know i'm
saying i mean the guy
he he he thinks like his leg was broken
the the in him before and then he still
come out there and tried to continue
competing more than i mean more than
it's a troop product yeah he he
he's the type of guy that i mean
the history behind him his
accomplishment i mean not incredible to
me he's one of the
best pitchers in the game
and i feel really bad for him because
you know i mean i know how to feel to go
to the war series you want to you want
to just give everything you have left in
the tank
to be able to win so i'm i'm i can't
imagine how we feel today he's uh david
ortiz mlb on fox analyst was it kevin
millar who put the ketchup on curt
schilling's sock or was it uh johnny
damon who tell us now uh
you know cause i i thought malar would
be the guy to put ketchup on chilling
socks so you can tell us now
david uh honestly
you know when i heard people talking
about that
uh
it is it made me laugh
uh to be honest because accidentally
i walk into the training room
when the doctor
the teen doctor
was performing
that little surgery i caught a little
surgery because he was in the training
room but obviously
i saw him that he was caught up and down
there
accidentally i walk into the train room
to get some tape because i used to wear
tape on my wrist
uh we had a we had a workout day that
day at yankee stadium
and
accidentally i walk in and when i saw
everybody like
on the one day what i was like what is
going on here and then i went and looked
and i was like
oh shoot what's going on here
they're performing a surgery right here
it blows my mind because i never thought
i was going to bump into something like
that
in a training room
so
[Music]
right away in my mind i like all damn
we're done because
you're talking about
one of
our prying
starter
basically
with ankle caught up and
so in my mind i'm thinking he's not
going to be able to [ __ ] yeah
and then a couple of days later the guy
is dealing in the mount on the mount so
i i heard all the story about ketchup
this and now blah blah blah and i'm like
i saw that with my own eyes
when he got that surgery like like
what is people talking about you don't
say so
uh
so it's hard to believe
that that was blood but i saw it that's
that's the thing i saw it like
if
put it this way if i was on the teen and
i never walk into the room
i'd be like whatever yeah i don't know i
mean who who in hell gonna be out there
performing with after after somebody
practiced the surgery but i saw it like
i was a witness
so
it was crazy it was something crazy uh
baseball fans can text road trip to
595959 and be entered for a chance to
win pair tickets to all 30 mlb stadiums
next season brand new rv to get you
there and you got to see the rv man
i saw it is it all tricked down super
nice it's super nice t-mobile making an
incredible job with that rv i mean
i don't i'm not a bro guy i mean
it's hard for me to stay on the road for
more than a couple hours but i would
take my chances on that rv to be honest
it's very comfortable so uh t-mobile's
giving you a chance to win everything
you need for the road trip of a lifetime
what's the wildest car
you ever had like
when you showed up everybody knew you
were there
probably a lamborghini what color
my first one was the yellow
your first lamborghini was yellow
yes what was the second one
white oh okay
do you ever get it up to
120
oh yeah
oh yeah in dominican you can take a
depressed you want
[Laughter]
i i i didn't mean to offend you that was
only 120 there poppy
not in the state man not in the state
but in domain again
you can hit as much as you want but you
know like
we have this one highway in the
dominican
where this uh
it's like it's straight up there's not
traffic there's not much traffic that
was where i used to go and test drive my
car but
yeah man you know i mean that's what you
get it for i mean
to know what's up what's happening what
time it is
uh how fast did you get it up to
200
200. yeah
for about five minutes
okay
maybe less than five minutes
was anybody in the car with you
uh yeah a friend of mine
[Laughter]
no but of course she did
younger
it wasn't manny ramirez who was sitting
there with you was it
no no no no no no no money money won't
allow me to money like the slow ride
how do you think this series plays out
it's going to be very it's going to be
very interesting to uh to see the end of
this uh series because
pretty much both things have pretty much
exactly the same
uh talent you know last night atlanta
basically take advantage of
houston it seems like to me i feel like
even the fans
give up after the first or second
meeting you know what i'm saying when
they saw that
valdez was giving it up
everybody like kind of
not the player but the fans i never had
seen anything like that before this is
like they quit
you don't say and i was like wait a
minute this place is very loud yeah and
he just got shut down
from the very beginning of the game so
atlanta take advantage of that and they
end up winning the game but
this is gonna be a long series i'm i'm
pretty sure you know because uh houston
they know how to fight back they this
houston is the type of thing that they
it seems like once they have the the
foot on on the troll you know that's
when they kind of like
start pulling their breasts out of there
so well
let's see if they can get their foot on
the lamborghini pedal and get it up to
200 miles an hour
by the way text road trip five nine two
five nine five nine five nine and your
chance to win what big poppy was talking
about the contest runs through november
third t-mobile the uh 5g network covers
the most interstate miles so this world
series t-mobile giving you a chance to
win everything you need for the road
trip of a lifetime
david great to talk to you again have
fun during the post season and uh thanks
for sharing
all right
that's a big papi